[Music]
foreign
deadly and sucking up every bit of
matter in its past
the most massive black hole in the known
universe is headed right toward Earth
what would you see as it started to
slurp up the Milky Way galaxy
what kind of tasty dish would Earth
become
and when it's finished with us where
would it go next
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the largest black hole entered
our solar system
black holes aren't that much different
from any other object in the universe
that has mass except that they are
really really dense at their Center is a
singularity an infinitely small point
where all its matter is compressed
the more matter that's condensed into
the singularity the stronger the
gravitational pull
most black holes are the remnants of
massive stars and generally range
between 10 to 100 solar masses
for the record one solar mass is the
equivalent of 333
000 Earths
that's a lot of gravity but super
massive black holes which lurk at the
centers of many galaxies could contain
millions or billions of solar masses and
scientists think that there are black
holes as large as 100 billion solar
masses
AKA stupendously large black holes or
slabs catch one of these moving toward
our solar system and get ready to wave
bye bye to all your conceptions of space
and time
yeah that's right it's time to say
alfredozane adios ciao now based on
context you probably know what I'm
saying here but if you want to have more
in-depth conversations in another
language you need to try speakally
I like to travel and you know there's
nothing more satisfying than visiting
somewhere new and talking to the locals
in their own language sharing stories
even having a laugh with speakally you
have access to a methodology that helps
you learn five times faster than
anything you've used before with only 30
minutes of daily practice you could go
from zero to solid speaking skills in
three to four months
everything is based on real life
situations so the words and phrases you
learn are relevant to your daily life
and it doesn't matter if you have an
Android or an iOS device just click on
the link to start your free seven-day
trial of speakally and get a 60 discount
if you join the annual subscription
languages bring us together but that
black hole might tear us apart
the largest known black hole ton 618 has
begun its long track directly toward our
solar system with its 66 billion solar
masses in tow and long Trek is no
overstatement it would be traveling at
least 10 billion light years to reach us
as it steamrolled through space it would
gobble every bit of dust and gas in its
path
it would also snack on many stars before
it even reaches the Milky Way depending
on its route this could mean hundreds of
billions of stars added to its size
before making first contact with our
galaxy it would have pulled in enough
matter to disrupt its neatly organized
spiral
you'd be able to detect its initial
approach toward us as You observe the
increasingly intense radiation it emits
eventually it would come bearing down on
the last of the Milky Way's spiral arms
the Orion arm
ton 618 would gobble up its entire 20
000 light year length it would be like
an unbelievably long Buffet line
straight to the center of our galaxy
somewhere along this line it would
finally knock on our front door
the orc cloud is a spherical shell of
icy debris that surrounds the solar
system
or at least it was before ton 618 showed
up
it would then continue on its way and
consume the Kuiper belt just beyond the
orbit of Neptune
the danger to Earth would steadily
increase as hundreds of thousands of icy
bodies would be sent hurtling this way
as ton 618 kept pushing forward
it would Devour the ice giants Neptune
and Uranus and the gas giants Saturn and
Jupiter would be pulled apart Adam by
Adam
not only the planets but their moons and
every asteroid that the giant black hole
comes across
any future plans by us to settle on Mars
would be squashed as the red planet
would end up right smack in the middle
of this black hole too
and now there would be nothing left in
the way of tons 618 and Earth
now while the center of this
stupendously large black hole would be
almost
295 billion kilometers away we'd finally
be right up against its Event Horizon
that's the boundary marking a black
hole's point of no return
the pull of its gravity would now be
totally inescapable
our whole planet would stretch out while
simultaneously getting more and more
compressed
eventually Earth would become like a
strand of spaghetti slurped into an
empty black void
then this black hole monstrosity would
gobble up the sun in one big gulp and
now at the center of what was once our
solar system tons 618 would occupy
nearly as much space it would extend
almost all the way to the inner edges of
what used to be the Oort cloud
and since it's not polite to leave any
food on your plate ton 618 would
continue on its path toward the black
hole at the center of the Milky Way
Sagittarius A star
as these two massive black holes Collide
the Collision would be so powerful that
it could cause ripples in the very
fabric of space-time
but hold on what happened to you as you
got pulled into the black hole
well that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]